شان اسرائيلي اخر دعت عائلات اسرائيليه من
منطقه غلاف غزه للمشاركه في مظاهره قباله
مقر الكنيست ومقر الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
القدس الغربيه للمطالبه باسقاط الحكومه
الحاليه بسبب اخفاق في صد هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر واخفاق في عاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه وكان عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين قد شاركوا في تجمع
احتجاجي استمر يوما كاملا في
لعا الاس الاسين من غ وشهد تل ابيب مظاهره
هي الاكبر منذ ب الحرب في مسعا للضغط على
الحكومه لجعل ملف المحتجزين في غزه
اولويه
ذا الخبر العاجل مره اخرى مراس سله
الجزيره اذا تقول نحو الفي اسرائيلي اذا
يتظاهرون قباله مقري الكنيست والحكومه
بالقدس مطالبين
باسقاط الحكومه حول ما جاء اذا في هذا
العاجل معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان التفاصيل
معك نعم بالفعل هنا قباله المقار الحكوميه
مقابل الكنيست والحكومه الاسرائيليه في
مدينه القدس مظاهره يشارك بها المئات وفق
التقديرات الاوليه للشرطه الاسرائيليه
اكثر من 2000 مشارك في هذه المظاهره التي
دعا اليها تحديدا سكان المناطق الحدوديه
في غلاف
غزه من اجل المطالبه باسقاط الحكومه
الحاليه بسبب اخفاق في صد هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر وايضا لاخفا قها في اعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه هذه ربما
المظاهره هي الابرز ضمن المطالبات بتنحي
واسقاط الحكومه تحديدا بعد اكثر من شهرين
على اقامه خيمه كانت هنا خيمه احتجاجيه
صغيره جدا يشارك بها بعض الافراد ومنذ
بدايه الحرب مطالبه باسقاط
حكومه اليمين المتطرف حكومه نتنياهو
واستبدالها بحكومه اخرى بسبب ما سموه
الاخفاق الكبير في صد الهجوم في السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي وايضا يطالبون بوقف هذه
الحرب ووقف الانتقام كما يسمونه من
الفلسطينيين في غزه وايضا هناك مطالب
بطبيعه الحال بالعمل الفوري من اجل التوصل
الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى واعاده الاسر
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه المشاركون
هنا يرفعون لافتات عده تتهم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بانها شريكه في تعذيب كما
يسمونه الاسرى في غزه وايضا
في الدم كما يقولون شريكه في اراقه دماء
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين على حد سواء
وانها وانها اخفقت في المره الاولى في
حمايتهم امنيا وانهم لن يسمحوا لها
بمواصله اداره شؤون شؤونهم الامنيه وبما
انها اخفقت في صد هذا الهجوم فانها ستخف
ايضا في اداره امورهم الاخرى من عودتهم
الى بلدات الغلاف وايضا من اعاده الاسرى
المحتجزين اذا يقولون
حاليا يجب اقالت هذه الحكومه فورا عليهم
الانصراف الى البيت الى الانصراف
ويتهمونهم انهم
اهملوا الاسرائيليين وانهم تخلوا عنهم في
المره الاولى في السابع من اكتوبر وانهم
لن يسمحوا لهم بتكرار ذلك من خلال ابقاء
هذه الحكومه التي يصفونها ايضا في
الشعارات التي يرفعونها بانها حكومه خراب
وحكومه ادت الى هذا الاخفاق والى اراقه
دماء الاسرائيليين عمليا هم يتهمون هذه
الحكومه بانها شريكه براقه دماء
الاسرائيليين في السابع من اكتوبر وايضا
بالتخلي عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في غزه هناك مطالبات بان يغادر الجانب
الاسرائيلي الى تقديم مقترح لتبادل الاسر
وعدم الاكتفاء دائما برفض مقترحات تقدمها
الدول الوسطاء تحت ذرائع مختلفه وفقا لما
يقولونه بان الحكومه لا تولي اهميه لاعاده
الاسره وبالتالي هي لا تبادر لتقديم
مقترحات من اجل صفقه تبادل وبالتالي هناك
ضغوطات في الشارع الاسرائيلي حاليا ومن
الواضح بان هذا الحراك يتنامى اكثر
ونر بان هناك دمج بين المظاهرات م يطالبون
باعاده الاسرى للعائلات لكن بالاساس ايضا
المطالبه باسقاط هذه الحكومه وهذا امر
لافت جدا في الحروب بالعاده يكون هناك
التفاف حول صناع القرار حول الحكومات حول
القاضى السياسيين والقاضى العسكريين لكن
ربما هذه هي المره الاولى في تاريخ
اسرائيل ان تبدا هناك مثل لهذه المظاهرات
المطالبه بتنحي الحكومه وباسط الحكومه في
خضم حرب حصل ذلك في السابق لكن كان عاده
يبدا مثل هذا الحراك بعد انتهاء الحرب
وليس في خضمها نعم نجوان لعلنا نتعرف اكثر
ايضا على ربما المرحله التي وصل اليها هذا
الجدل حول استرجاع الاسرى لدى مجلس الحرب
والحكومه الاسرائيليه وهل سجلت اي تغير في
المواقف نعم بالفعل ربما هذه المواقف التي
بدا يتحدث عنها الاعلام الاسرائيلي مؤخرا
عن
خلافات جذريه في كيفيه التعاطي مع قضيه
الاسرى ما بين التيار الذي يقوده رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه يوف
جلنت الذ الذان مازالا يتحدثان عن الضغط
العسكري زياده الضغط العسكري على غزه
سيؤدي الى اعاده اسرى المحتجزين
ابرام صفقه تبادل في مقابل ذلك هناك تيار
اخر بزعامه وزير الوزير في مجلس الحرب
بينان والوزراء من حزبه
ايديز يوم امس كانت له تصريحات لافته جدا
وشديده اللهجه ضد توجه بنيامين نتنه وزير
الا المحتجزين غزه ضمن الاولويات بل على
راس الاولويات في هذه الحرب وليس استمرار
الحرب والقتال ويقولون بان كل ما فعله
الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه لم يفلح
ولم ينجح
باستعاده اي من الاسرى المحتجزين بل على
العكس العمليات العسكريه عرضت حياه الاسرى
الى الخطر وكان هنا عد قتلوا خلال يات
عسكريه حاول من خلالها الجيش الاسرائيلي
تخليص او تحرير اسرى محتجزين في غزه لذلك
كان هناك يوم امس تصريحات من جادي ايزنكوت
وهو شخصيه بارزه جدا في الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه وهو وزير في مجلس الحرب وفقد
ابنه خلال المعارك في غزه خرج يوم امس او
سربت عنه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بانه امام
تحث ب
شء سياسه الحكومه في التمل مع قيه الاس
وقال جاء او حان الوقت لنعترف فشلنا في
اعادتهم ويجب علينا التحرك لا وقت لهؤلاء
والوقت ينفد وعلينا التحرك فورا من اجل
استعادتهم وتحريرهم بطرق اخرى من خلال
التوصل الى صفقه تبادل
اسر من القدس شكرا جزيلا لك